and this is what it looks like now as
people queue to get their chance to pass
by the queen's coffin and pay their
final respects the queen will lie in
state at westminster hall for four days
from five o'clock this evening until 6
30 a.m on monday morning many began
queuing overnight and have been braving
a very rainy london evening hoping to be
among the first to get into westminster
hall there were plenty of tents along
the river even though camping isn't
permitted lots of food and drink too to
see people through the night one chappie
even walked along offering pizza
the archbishop sent some pizza yeah yeah
we had hot pizza from the archbishop we
are wet
and we are maybe a bit cold
but you put up with it
it's worth it it'd be worth it will be
she was really an icon of an icon she
was a real legend of someone that
combined motherhood
with monarchy she produced the next king
yet
she was ruling her majesty reigned for
70 years
i can give her 24 hours
of my time to pay respects and say thank
you
for an incredible reign
i was just so adamant to come and pay my
respects to such a great lady
and um how do you feel about not having
a bed for the evening i'm okay i've got
my chair and got waterproofs and
something warm so what about food i've
got food and drink yeah
and there's people up and down with
pizza and hot tea and it's amazing
katie here this morning with me hello
katie just looking around what we uh the
dawn has broken for uh the queen for the
very last time here at buckingham palace
a very different mood this morning yeah
it is we've been here over the last few
days haven't we and at times when the
the queen's coffin was uh up in scotland
it it didn't feel that as serious it
felt more like people were very excited
for to catch a glimpse of of the new
king but i think yesterday evening when
the queen's coffin
was brought here as it made the very
slow journey from raf northhold to
people lined the streets
uh
in the driving rain the coffin being
lit up and as it was driven into
buckingham palace last night
that moment of silence
that sort of washed over the whole of
the the area over here for people
outside before they sort of broke into a
spontaneous round of applause
the seriousness of what's happened i
think has become a bit more real for
people here now i think i think that's
right i think people
couldn't comprehend couldn't take in
what had happened and
seeing her coffin uh arriving here
at raf northhold brought down from
edinburgh by the raf in very safe hands
there and then it processing along the
a40 with a specially designed hearse so
that as many people as possible could
see through the glass house to the
coffin lit up as well as you as you
quite rightly point out suddenly for so
many people
the realization was that we are that
that the queen was dead
yeah and it's a it's a funny mix of
emotions isn't it there's been a lot of
psychologists commenting over the last
few days why do we cry when we see this
moment for those people that haven't
even met the queen but have found it a
very emotional experience i think the
the consensus is this is a woman
because she reigned for 70 years for so
long that has accompanied all of us
through
major events in our our lives so i think
for a lot of people it's it makes you
think about your own life as well and
how she's been there as this consistent
presence throughout our lives and to
that end um the cues that we're seeing
on the south bank that will continue to
snake around the capital for the next
few days um a group of samaritans
will be wandering up and down that queue
to offer comfort support solace as and
when
it's necessary as far as that queue
is concerned it's going to stretch for
something just short
of five miles and it's going to go from
westminster hall right up to southwark
park the front of the queue is at the
palace of westminster
where there'll be airport-style security
from there it's going to wind its way
back through victoria tower gardens on
the embankment and across lambeth bridge
before going back on yourself again and
then on the opposite side of the river
thames it will stretch along the south
bank some pretty impressive uh monuments
along the way katy including the london
eye the tate modern
london bridge we know the bfi and south
bank's going to be playing archive of
the queen as well so it really will be
you'll be taking in the whole of
london and seeing sort of the
places that the queen went to throughout
her life i think i'm writing saying
he'll go past city hall as well and the
beauty the magnificence of tower bridge
and also the tower of london before it
reaches
the maximum permitted length which is at
um southwark park which is in burmancy
and we've done a calculation to suggest
that's around about five miles there's
plenty of loops in there as well so
perhaps um a little longer than five
miles and many of our viewers this
morning will be saying surely people
won't be queuing that long but they will
some suggestions
30 hours 30 hours seems an implausible
amount of time but all plans are in
place these people have been queueing
since six o'clock last night and it is
impressive a lot of them are older
people as well we've seen overnight just
the this is dry now at least it's dry
that's what i was going to say the
amount of rain that they've had to uh
put up with overnight
uh but people
are in good spirits they've just wanted
to really be among the the front few
people to witness this historic moment i
would say by joining this cue now though
you you are making the decision that
you're going to
not see the the
the procession that will be pretty
impressive that we'll see this afternoon
as the queen leaves the queen's coffin
leaves buckingham palace and it is by
gun carriage moved to westminster hall
itself i think that will be we saw
rehearsals yesterday in the very early
hours of the morning um
for the sort of things that you're going
to see and we saw the the military
uniforms the bands is going to be quite
a moment uh it is although you know if
you are in the queue and you've charged
up your phone you can get sky news um on
your phone live and so you will be able
to watch events as they start to
unroll from um about 2 22 p.m about
definitely exactly
and then it's a 38 minute journey and
perfectly paced as well that was the
point of having these the one rehearsal
that they managed to get yesterday of
course these things are meticulously
planned everything has to has to run to
time
and so for 38 minutes what they've done
what they were doing was working out the
exact pacing that you they want for uh
in order to make it to westminster hall
exactly on time uh we know that the the
procession itself will be um behind the
the gun carriage in which the the
queen's coffin uh is being transported
behind there the royal family will
follow on we knew that the the king and
his siblings would be following in
military uniform what we had
confirmation of overnight
was the fact that princess william and
and harry will to be joining
the royal family for for that moment